gleich zwei drucken besucher stehen für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
am donnerstag auf dem plan
am vormittag besuchte die militärpolizei
in der maria theresien kaserne und am
nachmittag die heeres bekleidungs
anstatt bei der militärpolizei
informiert sich die
verteidigungsministerin über das breite
einsatzspektrum des spezial verbandes
und zeigt sich beeindruckt bei einer
kleinen demonstration von
personenschützern der polizei ist eine
militärische erste reaktions kraft die
aufgrund ihrer ganz besonderen
spezifischen ausbildung mit
polizeilichen fähigkeiten ausgestattet
ist das brauchen wir
die verteidigungsministerien erinnert an
dieser stelle an den terroranschlag in
den vergangen ist denken wir an den
hinterhältigen furchtbaren
terroranschlag an den abend des 2
november im vorjahr zurück binnen
kürzester zeit musste das
innenministerium alle verfügbaren kräfte
zusammen ziehen und diesen
terroranschlag bewältigen zu können
zu einem zeitpunkt war das an dem die
schießerei noch im gange war
man hat ja zu dem zeitpunkt noch nicht
einmal gewusst wie viele terrorismus
genau waren und in welchen räumen die
täter noch am werk waren ja und da stand
die militärpolizei gemeinsam mit dem
jahr commander innerhalb kürzester zeit
zur verfügung um im notfall einspringen
zu können auch wenn es um den
personenschutz geht ist man bei der m
peter erste ansprechpartner jan dem
ausland das ist vielleicht nicht so sehr
bekannt leistet die militärpolizei als
permanente aufgabe derzeit mit 33
personen ihren beitrag im rahmen der
internationalen militär polizei samt
personenschutz im kosovo bosnien und
zukünftig wieder temporär dann
maly
[Musik]
am nachmittag besucht ministerin tanna
die heeres bekleidungs anstalt und
informiert sich über die aktuellen
standards peter harris bekleidung neu
sind dabei schwer entflammbare uniformen
für hubschrauberpiloten
grundsätzlich werden alle altenheim
fertigen uniformen durch die neuen
tarnmuster uniformen ersetzt weiter an
anzug schon ausgeliefert worden ist das
ist zb das panzergrenadierbataillon 13
18 oder das miliz jägerbataillon
burgenland und die anderen verbände
werden dann in der heeres bekleidungs
anstalt setzt man nicht mehr nur auf die
funktionalität der uniformen auch
verschiedene high tech funktionen müssen
erfüllt werden
lichtwellen gemessen das heißt es wird
gemessen ob der stoff des tarnanzüge
zurückstrahlt oder nicht auch beim
einsatz von nachtsichtgeräten in der
dunkelheit ist der neue tarnanzug
wesentlich schwerer zu erkennen und
bequemer zu tragen ist auch was aber
auch nicht so vernachlässigen ist ist
das auch die uniformen jetzt im schnitt
angepasst worden sind und mir ist das
immer wieder bei meinen truppen besuchen
auch berichtet worden bei denjenigen die
ihn schon erhalten haben die sachen
tragekomfort ohne zweifel bequemer
geworden